the most dangerous person in the world
is a man who's broken and alone what do
you mean by that I have been feeling and
seeing this notion of how poorly young
men are doing I just can see it in my
friends with their sons I have friends
who have two daughters and a son I'm
saying this metaphorically but the
younger daughters working at PR firm in
Chicago and the sun is in their basement
vaping and playing video games seven to
ten high school valedictorians or girls
for every one male college graduate over
the next five years there's going to be
two female college graduates 93 of
Massachusetts are men three times more
likely to overdose four times more
likely to commit 12 times more likely to
be incarcerated they do worse in single
parent households for some reason girls
have the same outcomes in a dual parent
household versus a single their
education system is biased against men
young men just have the deck stack
against them